they are a family in mourning
grieving the loss of a husband father
and grandfather
stepping in where the duke would once
have been supporting the monarch
the first official public tribute coming
from his eldest son
i i particularly wanted to say that
my father i suppose the last
uh 70 years has given the most
remarkable devoted service
to the queen to my family
and to the country and also to the whole
of the commonwealth
and as you can imagine my family and i
missed my father enormously he was a
much loved and appreciated figure
and apart from anything else i can
imagine
and we're so deeply touched by the
number of other people
here and elsewhere around the world in
the commonwealth who also i think
share our loss and our sorrow
and my my dear papa
was uh was a very special person who i
think above all else would have been
amazed
by the reaction and the touching things
that have been said about him
and from that point of view we are my
family deeply grateful
for all that it will sustain us in this
particular loss and at this particularly
sad time
thank you thank you
as the crowds gathered outside windsor
castle where he died on friday morning
other family members were visiting the
queen their son
prince andrew driving himself past the
well-wishers
in a separate car prince edward and the
counts of wessex drove slowly
thanking those who'd come to pay their
respects
sophie with tears in her eyes telling us
her majesty was doing
okay
he never wanted the pomp and ceremony
that his national service meant he was
entitled to
in the end the pandemic the reason his
funeral plans have been significantly
scaled back
the funeral will take place at windsor
castle next saturday
at three o'clock there'll be no public
access
or public processions and the event will
be within the current covid guidelines
but still very much reflect the personal
wishes of the duke
there will be a national minute silence
at three o'clock
we are still waiting for the full guest
list but his children
and grandchildren are expected to attend
including the duke of sussex but megan
who's expecting her second child
will not because of doctor's advice
in the procession from the castle st
george's chapel
his coffin will be moved inside a
specially modified land rover
there has been this spontaneous
gathering here in windsor with people
wanting to
bring flowers and pay their respects and
in some ways that is difficult for the
royal family
they don't want to be seen to be
encouraging people to gather in crowds
during the pandemic but they also
acknowledge that there are members of
the public who want to share
in their moment of grief and that's why
they're encouraging
everyone to watch the funeral on
television rather than come here
in person in recent years
since he retired the queen's official
duties meant they had spent time apart
the pandemic bringing them back together
at windsor
a no-nonsense couple of that wartime
generation
it is still inevitable that many will
wonder how she'll cope
after losing her life partner the queen
is very resilient by nature
and she has a very strong uh religious
faith so i think that is all
uh a help in this time when obviously
it's a it's a time of grief
as well as of accepting this new
situation but it's one that
i think the queen would have anticipated
and would be coping with
the family have always described
themselves as her
supporting cast their comfort never
needed more
as they prepared to give the duke of
edinburgh a fitting
farewell rhiannon mills sky news
at windsor castle